I've definitely been caught many times
in my car being a silly actor and I'm
going at it at a stoplight and I'm just
like letting this person have it this
imaginary person in front of me and then
I look over and it's like sweet older
ladies looking at me she's just
absolutely terrified and I do a big grin
and I'm like hey yo look at this the web
in full effect
so I get to take this home write about
to rock this tonight Saturday night is
Jody Corolla I started acting in New
York I had always been waiting for LA to
call my name I was going to pack all my
stuff up and leave you just got to take
the leap of faith right it was probably
the best decision I ever made
as an actor I was always in the pursuit
it never ends the rituals never end
either which is changing in your car
getting ready for auditions doing lines
in your car it was a 1999 silver Toyota
Corolla
it was my ride-or-die so much excitement
behind this wheel so I'd kick off my
heels hard some were very discreet and I
would change in the backseat from
character to character you know nerd
glasses the tape I definitely remember
auditioning for the role of like chola
number three what you say didn't book it
what do you got you go through this
journey of trying so hard to be what
everybody else wants oh here we're
looking at me got it all over my teeth
again
jeez Gina and then just like rolling
down the window and letting them breeze
away great all right next one then it
didn't need to happen overnight
and I'll always remember that it wasn't
until I came into loving the person that
I was as me as myself that's when it
really hit yes just like be true to you
Oh
gangsters wear seatbelts